Things have changed since Arsalan Kazemi's Iranian parents,...
...enrolled their son at a prep school in North Carolina.
The gamble paid off when basketball powerhouses such as Memphis,...
...Maryland, and Oklahoma State all offered him full athletic scholarships,...
...but Arsalan chose a different offer.
He signed with Rice University in Houston, Texas...
...over other better-known basketball programs.
I didn't want to sit on the bench for an entire year, my freshman year.
It just doesn't work with my mentality.
And secondly, because Rice is a very good school academically,...
...I knew I could get a great job after graduating from here.
That great job may have to wait.
After a successful freshman year at Rice,...
...scouts noticed Arsalan at the Basketball World Championships in Turkey...
...in the summer of 2010.
In my first year here, everyone talked about me...
...being the first-ever Iranian to receive a scholarship in the NCAA.
That's why it was such a good feeling after the World Championships.
Then, everyone, all the reporters all of a sudden started talking about basketball with me...
...and telling me I'm a great player, and that I have a future. It was a great feeling.
A reporter for Slam Magazine picked Arsalan as one of the top five NBA draft prospects of the tournament.
After this year, I would really like to sign up for the draft,...
...practice with teams to compare myself to other players,...
...and see what areas I need to improve upon.
Then, come back for my junior year at Rice,...
...work on those areas, and then make my move fully after that season.